[Music]
guys sometimes a play is so epic so
perfectly timed so clutch then it lives
on forever in league of legends as an
iconic moment unfortunately the same can
also be said for the worst of the worst
miss plays so from Bad Baron plays that
lost the game to the most infamous halt
that never happened here are the top 10
miss plays in league of legends to kick
off our list of fails we've got one
that's so well known it's become a meme
in what has since become known as
pulling a dyrus we have what might be
one of the funniest images in league
history as the casters and the camera
are focused on the early game mid lane
matchup they're interrupted abruptly the
first at 5 and now we have 3 at 8
minutes and 30 seconds so at least all
the minutes since 5 they've really been
picking up kills for themselves oh I I
do I'm gonna go ahead and say that
wasn't on TSM the website
he pulled a dyrus he died farming wolves
8 and a half minutes into the game the
flash summoner spell is undoubtedly the
most important and powerful in league of
legends and when a flash goes wrong it
goes really wrong coming in at number 9
x-pac a shows us just how bad a flash
can be he blinks over the wall directly
in the middle of the teamfight and his
health bar melts on sight but now he's
isolated from the team caught in a
cocoon
in comes the Viking power goes cold and
so as trying to provide the backup will
he be able to do it Peck a flash over
the wall and do they have the damage
nuke Doug certainly does to equalize
pecky but he tried to play Sivir like a
middling mage not a lot of burst damage
there at number 8 double if shows us
that even the best in the world need to
ease their way back into competitive
play sometimes after a tough teamfight
we're Team Liquid had their backs
against the wall double lift and the
surviving members of TL look to regroup
and farm up double rotates to the red
buff and gets ready for the possibility
of another fight little did he know that
the real fight was right in front of him
as
Dyess embarrassingly to the cold claws
of the red bramble back red buff you
died to something that he wasn't
supposed to die to now we're gonna get
the moment I think you're right patient
yeah I mean it's gonna sneak up on you
you're reloading I mean really it could
happen to anyone
nothing brings you back to earth quite
like being punked out by an NPC in front
of tens of thousands of people at number
seven we've got what can only be
described as a swing Animists if you've
ever played league you're definitely
familiar with just how game breaking and
strong Annie's ultimate can be that is
if you can actually hit your opponents
with it unfortunately kiwi-kid was
unable to land assault after flashing
forward and unleash timbers into well
nobody they really need a big play from
Annie and this is the type of character
that cute kid loves because it's a
game-changing character he can turn the
tides of an entire game by landing a
multiband stun a pretty slow game I
think is I don't know is gravity oh
there's the what not the play I was
looking for what I he sees saw ghosts
hello what maybe I also recall that we
missed it might have been actually when
it comes to throwing games in the North
American LCS perhaps no one is as
noteworthy as Coast they're the
champions of giving it all away and here
is maybe the greatest example of just
that Coast held a small lead over
Dignitas until their mid laner jezza's
got caught out to which they responded
by trying to force Baron and number six
we've got one of these stranger calls
you're ever likely to see dig was able
to counter by simply walking their team
down mid lane and destroying hosts Nexus
they probably go for that and they have
all the time in the world here to trade
for their
don't trade this because you're my
sister by the Baron takes too long to
kill what are they thinking that's bad
news bears I do not know where that call
just made okay she couldn't run
seasonings are that's not a powered
trance I go boil through the entire team
that's gonna put the nail in the coffin
and after being on their heels for the
past seven minutes Dignitas is going to
take down the Nexus to win their first
game for the North American spring split
Wow coast vision control is arguably the
single most important thing in League of
Legends whichever team has eyes on the
majority of the map is often the one
with a lead here we see a hilarious
example of this Samsung all pile into a
bush looking to catch nausea off-guard
and land a pic little do they know
nausea has vision at number four we've
got the flash or lack thereof heard
around the league of legends community
we all know that at the center of any
good league meme is a usually hilarious
miss play and maybe no pro player meme
is as ubiquitous as double lifts flash
still being up here's where it all
started at Worlds in 2017 his team is
wrapped up in a brutal team fight
against misfits and then double dies
with that damn flash sitting there
simply unused
the one who's caught out yet again I get
[ __ ] right here and I 100% agree this
is a situation where I should have
flashed 100% I don't need to get it by
chain or the e flash from drag Asst I
didn't react in time when you cue into a
game of League of Legends you're
expecting a five versus five match an
even affair that will inevitably
determine a winner but sometimes that
opposing turret feels like the six man
you thought you never had to worry about
and other times the opposing teams make
you feel a little bit better by getting
double killed by the rift Herald at
number three we've got maybe the
funniest clip out there to NPCs getting
the better of four Pro League of Legends
players take the turret so you get the
gold back right did they shut down the
turret the runner up on our list comes
from the 2017 League of Legends World
Championship North America had high
hopes for immortals at Worlds 2017 but
after posting a middling two and two
group stage record looked to get back on
track against an O and for fnatic squad
as fnatic started to turn the tide of a
key late-game teamfight immortal star
Cody Sun tried to make a big play to
clutch it out but it was more than a
little awkward
loses his mind by flashing into an
entire team at the end and we talked
about of all the Miss plays on this list
this one may have been the most costly
TSM and cloud9 were facing off in Game
five of the na LCS finals and the two
rivals were neck and neck when the
game's pivotal teamfight broke out in
what is maybe the most memorable alt
that never happened
Jensen just never chrono breaks in this
teamfight and TSM are able to capitalize
and win the title taking the top spot on
our list is that most impactful ultimate
that never happened to try keep them out
reduce it down right
[Applause]
Romani pocket in the fight smoothie pop
new logos down gonna take hold of dragon
as well
Jetson didn't get his odious off didn't
get his ultimate off he goes down in the
critical fight
[Applause]
again healthy
champions cloud
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button